[Music]
procopius of Caesarea has written the
history of the wars which Justinian
emperor of the Romans waged against the
barbarians of the East and of the West
relating separately the events of each
one to the end did the long course of
time may not overwhelm deeds of singular
importance through lack of a record and
thus abandoned them to oblivion and
utterly obliterate them the memory of
these events he deemed would be a great
thing and most helpful to men of the
present time and to future generations
as well in case time should ever again
place men under a similar stress for men
who purpose to enter upon a war or are
preparing themselves for any kind of
struggle which may derive some benefits
from a narrative of a similar situation
in history in as much as this disclosure
the final result attained by men of an
earlier day in a struggle of the same
sort and foreshadows at least for those
who are most prudent in planning what
outcome present events will probably
have
furthermore he had assurance that he was
especially competent to write the
history of these events if for no other
reason because it fell to his loss when
appointed advisor to the general
Belisarius to be an eyewitness of
practically all the events to be
described it was his conviction that
while cleverness is appropriate to
rhetoric and inventiveness to poetry
truth alone is appropriate to history in
accordance with this principle he has
not concealed the failures of even his
most intimate acquaintances but has
written down with complete accuracy
everything which befell those concerned
whether it happens to be done well or
ill by them it will be evident that no
more important or mightier deeds are to
be found in history the knows which have
been enacted in these wars provided one
wishes to base his judgment on the truth
for in them more remarkable feats have
been performed that in any other Wars
with which we are acquainted unless
indeed any reader of this narrative
should give the place of honor to
antiquity and consider contemporary
achievements unworthy to be counted
remarkable
there are these for example who call the
soldiers of the present-day bowmen well
to those of the most ancient times they
wish to attribute such lofty terms as
hand-to-hand fighters shield men and
other names of that sort and they think
that the valour of those times is by no
means survived to the present an opinion
which is at once careless and wholly
remote from actual experience of these
matters for the thought has never
occurred to them that as regards the
Homeric bowmen who had the misfortune to
be ridiculed by this term derived from
their art they were neither carried by
horse nor protected by spare or shield
in fact there was no protection at all
for their bodies they entered battle on
foot and were compelled to conceal
themselves either singling out the
shield of some comrade or seeking safety
behind a tombstone or on a mound from
which position they could neither save
themselves in case of rout nor fall upon
a flying foe
least of all could they participate in a
decisive struggle in the open but they
always seemed to be stealing something
which belongs to the man who were
engaged in the struggle and apart from
this they were so indifferent in their
practice of archery that they drew the
bowstring only to the breasts so that
the missile sent forth was naturally
impotent and harmless to those who it
hit such it is evident was the archery
of the past but the bow men of the
present time go into battle wearing
corsets and fitted out with Greaves
which extend up to the knee from the
right-side hand their arrows from the
other the sword and there are some who
have a spare also attached to them and
at the shoulders a sort of small shield
without a grip such as to cover the
region of the face and neck
they are expert horseman and are able
without difficulty to direct their bows
to either side while riding at full
speed and to shoot an opponent whether
in pursuit or in flight they draw the
bow string along by the forehead about
opposite the right ear thereby charging
the arrow with such an impetus as to
kill whoever stands in their way
shield and courselet alike having no
power to check its force
still there are those who take into
consideration none of these things
reverence and worship the ancient times
and give no credit to modern
improvements but no such consideration
will prevent the conclusion that most
great and notable deeds have been
performed in these wars and the history
of them will begin at some distance back
telling of the fortunes in war of the
Romans and the Medes their reverses and
their successes
[Music]
you
[Music]